ela deve falar bom dia
beleza direto ao ponto nos próximos anos
não vai mais existir advogado
quando você olha pra mim eu escutei
dizendo isso alguns você falar porque
bom não gosta de rogado não confio no
advogado advogado é caro
outros bom olhar pra mim pensar pô mais
um geração y no palco falando que tudo
vai mudar e etc etc mas o fato é eu sou
advogado
o motivo está falando isso pra vocês é
que no futuro não vai mais existir
advogado como a gente conhece ele hoje
os advogados do futuro vão ser muito
diferentes de como a gente conhece
certamente em menor número e certamente
muito melhor muito mais eficiente para
discutir com vocês a minha visão sobre o
futuro do direito e eu repito é a minha
visão eu tenho uma pergunta uma impedido
e uma proposta para fazer
vamos começar pela primeira como que a
gente faz para transformar uma área que
é tão conservadora em um mundo que está
girando tão rápido está evoluindo tão de
forma tão dinâmica é outro dia ouvi uma
frase que foi muito interessante não
conseguiu localizar o autor que ela já
foi traduzido e adaptado algumas vezes
mas fato é a gente não está vivendo uma
era de mudanças e sim uma mudança de era
e olhar pra isso e nos fazem entender a
magnitude do momento em que a gente está
vivendo nos últimos anos
é a gente se a gente olhar para o que
aconteceu nos últimos anos a internet
ela mudou a forma como a gente acesso à
informação como a gente se comunica e
como a gente trabalha hoje como o
celular na mão é possível contratar e
oferecer serviços é possível isso muda o
jogo o mundo hoje é completamente
conectado e digital até 2020 alguma
todas as profissões do mundo vão ter
algum aspecto digital envolvido é a
internet ela trouxe pra gente novos
modelos de negócio novas formas de
trabalhar até um pouco tempo atrás era
impensável que a maior rede de
transporte privado do mundo não tivesse
um carro é a maior rede de hospedagem
não tivesse uma cama se quer que o maior
portal de vendas não tivesse
toque e hoje isso nos faz refletir sobre
os conceitos que até então a gente tinha
como certos
basicamente o que a gente está vivendo
uma espécie de nova revolução agora
tecnológica em que as profissões vão ser
desafiados algumas já deixaram de
existir outras estão totalmente
ameaçadas tem um autor inglês que chama
richard seus cães
em 99 ele publicou um livro
superpolêmico que chama de end of lovers
o fim dos advogados e desde então esse
cara fica viajando pelo mundo pregando
pelo fim das profissões mais
tradicionais principalmente do direito
ele fala é que daqui a pouco as máquinas
não ficar tão inteligentes que a gente
não vai querer e tampouco precisar
contratar um advogado
eu particularmente não concordo com ele
existe um aspecto muito humano na
prática do direito
mesmo com a evolução da internet ainda
existe uma um aspecto muito humano
olhando de forma mais geral sobre essa
questão da da substituição das
profissões recentemente foi publicado um
estudo que mostrou que 5% das profissões
hoje existentes podem sim nos próximos
anos ser totalmente substituída pela
máquina
no caso dos advogados em especial a
white ea universidade da carolina do
norte nos estados unidos eles
pesquisaram e mostraram que 13% das
atividades dos advogados americanos já
pode e algumas já estão sendo
substituídas por máquinas
no caso do brasil esse número um pouco
maior mas ainda assim a pergunta que
fica é
os advogados então estão em uma posição
de conforto diante dessa desse fato
absolutamente não
o que acontece nos últimos nos próximos
20 anos a gente vai viver muito mais
transformação do direito do que a gente
viveu nos últimos 200 até agora o grande
é a grande virada no direito no mundo
foi a impressora foi a impressão barata
foi tirar o acesso o livro como um
artigo de luxo e transformar o
conhecimento disponível a todos
a internet fez basicamente isso e hoje é
o que acontece é uma transformação total
na forma como as pessoas trabalham
eu costumo comparar o a evolução do
direito a transformação do direito com o
aquecimento global para ficar mais fácil
de entender
a gente sabe que existe a gente escuta
falar mas a gente não vê os efeitos dela
o tempo todo na nossa pele não senti
isso a todo momento
a questão é para os dois casos o ponto
de virada tá muito mas muito mais
próximo do que a gente imagina
no caso do aquecimento global é é a
próxima página é uma página um pouco
caótica no caso do direito por outro
lado é uma página de absoluta
oportunidade vocês repararam mas meu
sotaque eu não sou daqui eu nasci e
cresci em belo horizonte e eu lá estava
trabalhando como advogado de uma grande
empresa e aí é por perceber essa mudança
por perceber essa oportunidade eu falei
eu quero fazer parte disso de forma
ativa eu quero estar na frente tocando
essa transformação do brasil
e aí contrariando meus amigos a minha
família e até mesmo meu chefe que falou
que tava fazendo a maior burrada da
minha vida eu abandonei a minha vida
corporativa numa das maiores empresas do
brasil para em pouco tempo e para lá no
vale do silício junto com meu sócio e a
gente criou uma empresa chamada lynch
para transformar de fato a forma como os
advogados as empresas e as pessoas lidam
com processos e contratos aqui no brasil
hoje a gente está fazendo as empresas
economizarem tempo e dinheiro o que a
gente acredita é que os advogados podem
sim ser menos operacionais e mais
estratégicos
eles podem parar de ficar copiando e
colando modelos e cobrando uma fortuna
por isso ea gente de fato está fazendo
parte de uma transformação muito
interessante
o legal disso é ver que a gente não está
sozinho e que existe um movimento grande
de pessoas inovando no direito a gente
olhar para o lado é muito fácil perceber
que as coisas vão ficando mais fáceis
antigamente para pegar uma certidão a
gente tinha que ficar horas numa fila de
seção eleitoral certidão de distribuição
etc
para consultar um processo tinha que até
o fórum para abrir um processo que tinha
que pedir um advogado para fazer isso
hoje em dia a internet permite que a
gente consulte os nossos dados a gente
abra processo não se querem abrir a
gente pode simplesmente resolver os
nossos conflitos online existe uma
tendência muito forte para que a gente
crie negocie e assine contratos usando a
internet e poderia ficar que horas dando
exemplo de pessoas por exemplo
existem sites incríveis estão conectando
pessoas com a justiça permitindo que a
gente encontre e contrata advogados
online
isso reduz a assimetria de informação e
coloca a informação precisa na mão das
pessoas
se a gente olhar pra frente os mesmos
protocolos por exemplo bloch tinta
revolucionando o mercado financeiro essa
mesma tecnologia pode acabar com os
cartórios aqui no brasil daqui muito
pouco tempo
se a gente olhar pra frente a gente vai
começar a usar bebedeira cruzamento de
dados públicos para tomar decisões
a gente vai ter inteligência artificial
aplicada ao direito para decidir e para
gerar contratos para analisar dados e
tomar decisões
isso é muito forte o que acontece hoje
algumas coisas que eu falo podem soar
como ficção científica mas daqui há
muito pouco tempo como smartphone é hoje
isso vai ser óbvio agora para inovar
para dar o próximo passo eu tenho um
pedido pra vocês
no caso do direito a gente precisa
encarar as coisas de forma mais simples
o que acontece hoje a gente é muito
resistente a mudar
a gente tende a complicar muito as
coisas se a gente olhar para as nossas
leis para o nosso sistema para a forma
como a gente se comporta existe um
abismo gigantesco entre a lei e o
comportamento humano com a internet esse
abismo ele ficou mais evidente ea
distância cada vez maior o que acontece
a gente se comporta de uma forma cada
vez mais dinâmica e a lei não consegue
direito não consegue acompanhar essa
evolução
a prática do direito também porque a
gente tende a complicar tudo até 2005
seria uma ideia era crime trair aqui no
brasil você ter uma idéia a gente
poderia ter discutido hoje transporte
alternativo carros alto dirigíveis mas
não a gente está brigando por uma lei de
táxi da década de 60
a gente é muito apegado às regras do
passado e quando eu olho para os
advogados em vez de eles quererem olhar
para frente
muitos deles estão se apegando às regras
do passado
então eu falo pra ele sempre gente
alguém precisa contar que advogado não
precisa ser chamado de doutor que o
direito não é uma profissão nobre ele é
igual como todas as outras
advogar é acessar as pessoas à justiça
se o mundo fosse mais simples não
precisava de tanta gente para explicar o
que a lei serve
não para fazer então é a gente precisa
encarar as coisas de uma forma mais
simples e menos resistente a mudar agora
é muito fácil para mim vir aqui estou
participando trabalha com tecnologia é
muito fácil vir aqui e dizer não vamos
ser mais simples e tal
o que a gente precisa ser é o usuário
mais crítico a gente tem que ser o
agente já que a gente é usuário do
direito e usuários da tecnologia porque
a gente não faz isso de uma forma mais
simples do que a gente não conecta o
direito e usa o direito pra garantir a
tecnologia e usa a tecnologia para
garantir o direito a gente tem que ser
usuário mais crítico mas desde
pequenininho hoje quando a gente usa o
smartphone eu vejo gente apertando
botões sem criatividade nenhuma e gente
usa o direito e convivi com ele também
sem criatividade nenhuma
como é que a gente pode de fato
transformar e fazer parte dessa evolução
pra mim a minha proposta é que a gente
pensa na educação que acontece quando
estava na faculdade eu ficava revoltado
porque aqueles conceitos todos de
direito constitucional direito civil
pra mim aquilo tinha que ser ensinado na
escola eu falei meu deus não faz sentido
nenhum eu ficar decorando tabela
periódica sendo que eu podia ter
aprendido a conviver melhor entender
melhor como o meu país funciona hoje eu
vejo que estava um pouco ingênua ou
então parcialmente certo
mais do que direito eu acho que na
escola as crianças têm que aprender
sobre tecnologia elas têm que aprender
sobre o pensamento computacional sobre
programação para que elas possam crescer
de uma forma mais crítica no fórum mais
analítica
além de direita claro e na faculdade o
que é muito pior
os advogados eles são formados hoje
aprendendo decorar códigos aprendendo a
pensar sobre alê tudo o que já foi
escrito e a decorar o que acontece o
advogado está sendo formado hoje ele não
é nem preparado para o presente que dirá
para o futuro
então o que a gente precisa fazer é
levar pra para os profissionais e para
as crianças habilidades que são de fato
necessárias num mundo mais dinâmico como
por exemplo inteligência emocional
raciocínio lógico pensamento
computacional criatividade o que a gente
precisa de fato hoje não são de
advogados que pensa e consigam escrever
um contrato então decorar toda a
legislação isso o computador
já faz vai fazer cada vez melhor o que a
gente precisa é de um advogado que
consiga entender de tecnologia operar as
máquinas mas principalmente fazer o que
ela não sabe fazer que é compreender o
ser humano e se relacionar melhor e
nesse último aspecto desde está deixando
muito a desejar
obrigado